which improvised scene nearly got Chris
Pratt fired and what show did Adam Scott
leave behind to become Ben Wyatt come
with us back to Pawnee and learn the
secrets behind Parks and Recreation
Parks and Recreation co-creator Greg
Daniels is also the man responsible for
bringing the office from British TV to
American audiences after turning that
show into a hit Daniels was tasked with
pitching a new series so he recruited
Michael schur a producer and writer for
the office to assist according to the
New York Times the new show wasn't
always supposed to be about a Parks and
Recreation Office in a small Indiana
Town it was almost a spin-off that
existed in the same universe as the
office given its early casting of office
Alum Rashida Jones everything changed
once Amy Poehler joined the show Fresh
Off Iran is the longest serving female
cast member on Saturday Night Live the
comedian completely changed the
trajectory of Daniel's insurance plan
project given her popularity they
decided to put polar at the center of
their new mockumentary where the show
would take place was another question
following the 2008 presidential election
Daniel's insurer felt inspired by the
country's growing optimism in regards to
politics Barack Obama had run for
president on a campaign of Hope and
change and managed to win they decided
to craft their new series around polar's
character of Leslie Noe an optimist
working in public service what I here
when I'm being yelled at is people
caring loudly at me
the role of Leslie in Parks and
Recreation was specifically written with
polar in mind production was even
delayed to accommodate her pregnancy at
the start of the show Leslie is the
deputy director of the parks department
in Pawnee Indiana a fictional Town whose
absurdity Rivals out of Springfield from
The Simpsons it isn't uncommon for a
sitcom to take its time finding its
footing and during the sixth episode
first season Leslie was unfavorably
compared to Steve Carell's Michael Scott
from the office one of the biggest
criticisms of Leslie's portrayal in the
first season was that her character came
off as incompetent or some critics put
it ditzy according to co-creator sure
their intention for Leslie was to be
smart although perhaps a little naive
something that didn't initially come
across the audiences seemingly Against
All Odds the show was renewed by NBC for
a second season allowing the writers
time to improve the character as the
show went on Leslie became more than a
punching bag for other characters that
role went to Jerry Leslie's optimism
doesn't make her naive and makes her
inspiring by the end of the series she's
come a long way from the overly eager
Park director of the pilot she's a
politician a leader and a mother all at
once foreign what about bringing mark on
board
which Mark which mark
Mark brandanowicz witch Mark fans of the
show's later Seasons may have forgotten
about Mark brandanowitz played by Paul
Schneider don't worry the writers did
too this character a city planner and
on-again off-again romantic interest of
Leslie's was in the main cast during the
first season however according to
Michael sure they always plan to have
Mark's appearances become rarer as the
show went on to reflect the reality of
the careers of city planners the end of
season 2 of Parks and Recreation
coincided with Schneider's departure
from the series sure claimed that this
was in line with their plans for the
character but the decision was also
influenced by Schneider's increased
success in films like bright star and
the assassination of Jesse James by the
coward Robert Ford despite yours claims
that Schneider would return for guest
appearances though that never came to
pass despite Mark's importance to the
show in the first two seasons the
characters never mentioned after his
departure from Pawnee not even by
Rashida Jones's Anne Perkins who dated
Mark during the second season Snyder
didn't return for the show's final
season and told the press that he wasn't
interested
Nick offerman's mustachioed Ron Swanson
is one of the true breakout characters
of Parks and Recreation he's the polar
opposite of polar's Leslie Knope deadpan
masculine and stoic however the
differences between the two characters
goes beyond personality Swanson is now
spoken libertarian with a strong
opposition to big government which puts
him at odds with nope's desire for
bureaucratic change in Pawnee this has
some basis in real life U.S politicians
according to the series co-creators as
Michael sure has told it Swanson's
opposition to government control is
based on a Libertarian government
official the creators met while doing
research for the show when sure pointed
out the contradiction between the
officials political stance and their
office of Duty the response apparently
was I don't really believe in the
mission of my job I like saying no
it lowers their enthusiasm this made for
the perfect opportunity to cast Offerman
who was favored by sure and Daniels
after the actor missed out on a part in
the office many aspects of Ron Swanson's
personality were inspired by Nick
Offerman himself the two share a lot in
common such as their love of Woodworking
and the saxophone when casting Swanson's
antagonistic ex-wife Tammy II it was
sure his idea to bring in opperman's
real life spouse will and gray star
Megan Mullally it's safe to say the show
wouldn't be what it is without
offerman's dry humor stealing every
scene he's in
it's hard to imagine Parks and
Recreation with a different cast
especially since most of the characters
were designed with certain actors in
mind at least that's what happened with
Aubry Plaza's role of April Ludgate at a
q a with the cast at the Paley Center
Michael sure recounted how the show's
casting director Allison Jones sent
Plaza to meet him with a preface that
she was the weirdest girl she'd ever met
it only took one meeting for sure and
Daniels to be sufficiently intrigued
Plaza's account to the meeting is a
little different she claims she wasn't
aware she was auditioning for anything
still an inspired sure to write a scene
between Leslie and an assistant named
Aubry the character over the course of
developing the pilots evolved into April
the Parks and Recreation Department's
apathetic intern with a morbid sense of
humor April along with Ron Swanson
became one of the show's breakout
characters and launched Plaza's career
into the A-list it's not hard to see how
Plaza's personality inspired the
character like April she seems to relish
uncomfortable situations often making
use of the deadpan humor that turned
April into a fan favorite an interview
between Aubry Plaza and Conan O'Brien
can get fans of Parks and Recreation an
idea of how the first meeting sure might
have gone my mother has all my baby
teeth in her underwear drawer
what
before Chris Pratt became Star-Lord the
wisecracking leader of Marvel's
Guardians of the Galaxy he broke out as
the dim-witted Andy Dwyer on Parks and
Recreation the character debuts in the
pilot as the boyfriend of Rashida
Jones's Aunt whose legs are broken after
he falls into the empty construction pit
that the first season centers around
filling as it turns out their breakup at
the end of that season was meant to be
the end of Andy's time on the show
fortunately for Pratt The Producers
liked the character so much that he was
promoted from guest star to main cast
for season 2. in order to allow him to
bump into other members of the cast Andy
was given a job as a shoe Shiner at City
Hall an early idea from the writers
would have seen Andy eventually become
mayor of Pawnee by the end of the series
since everybody who meets him loves him
sadly this idea never came to fruition
but Andy did take on several other jobs
throughout the show serving as Leslie's
campaign assistant and the host of the
Johnny karate super awesome musical
explosion show despite Pratt's growing
Fame during the early 2010s Andy's
presence on the show was never
compromised in between shooting
Guardians of the Galaxy along with films
like Zero Dark Thirty Pratt gained and
lost weights in order to keep Andy's
body shape according to Pratt Andy's
weight became vital to his character
underscoring Andy's misplaced confidence
and how pity is so the only thing you
did was stop drinking beer yeah I lost
50 pounds in one month
how much beer were you drinking I know
right
leave it to Chris Pratt to have more fun
on set than everybody else often his
improvisations made it onto the show
assuming that his co-stars didn't
immediately burst out laughing one of
those unscripted moments however almost
cost him his job the scene in question
was filmed for the season 2 episode
Kaboom in which Andy shows up to Anne's
house completely naked under the
mistaken belief that she wants him back
but Leslie answers the door instead on
the day of filming Pratt recognized that
polar wasn't reacting the way she would
if she actually saw Andy naked so he
surprised polar in his birthday suit
this ended up being the take they used
on the show meaning that millions of
people watched her genuinely react to
Pratt's nudity when telling the story on
talk shows like Graham Norton Pratt has
recounted how the take led to a formal
letter from NBC Executives reprimanding
him for the incident according to Pratt
he has a letter framed and hung in his
home office but it was enough to keep
him from flashing any other cast members
as far as We Know
prior to playing accounting whiz and
former kid mayor Ben Wyatt Adam Scott
was known for supporting roles in
comedies like Step Brothers and knocked
up and he got himself the lead role of
Henry on the Stars sitcom party down the
series had a lot of Hollywood names
involved in its production including
Paul Rudd Veronica Mars Creator Rob
Thomas and Fred Savage unfortunately the
show was doomed after two of its Stars
Scott and Jane Lynch moved on to other
projects Lynch joined the cast of Glee
while Scott was offered the role of Ben
Wyatt at the end of the second season of
Parks and Recreation he joined the show
alongside Rob Lowe's Chris Trager and
his character later began dating Leslie
then becomes a central member of the
Parks and Recreation family and that
wasn't what Drew Scott to the part since
the future of party down was up in the
air when Parks Came Calling it's kind of
said it was an easy choice to make as
especially due to the fact that Parks
and Recreation was one of his favorite
TV shows at the time the feeling was
Mutual with the showrunners Scott was
their number one choice to play Ben as
for party down it took 13 years but the
show was finally revived and broadcast
in 2023 with Adam Scott included
Rob Lowe made his Parks and Recreation
debut alongside Adam Scott in the season
2 episode The Master Plan his character
of government auditor Chris Trager is
positive energetic and health conscious
to an absurd degree making him a perfect
foil for characters like Ron and April
if I keep my body moving and my mind
occupied at all times I will avoid
falling into a bottomless pit of despair
while the roll garnered Rob Lowe heaps
of praise it wasn't always the plan for
him to join the main cast Chris was
meant to be a guest spot for low who was
initially slated to appear at the end of
season 2 as well as the first six
episodes of season three between Seasons
two and three though Lowe signed on to
join the main cast the addition of low
is a series regular was fruitful for
Anne Perkins Rashida Jones's character
had gone through many flings throughout
the show but through Chris Trager and
found an end game and the relationship
was well received by critics and
audiences alike
comedian and future voice of Sonic the
Hedgehog Ben Schwartz portrayed one of
the most popular recurring characters on
Parks and Recreation he originally met
with Creator Michael sure for a
different role a potential love interest
for Leslie no that we didn't land the
part a character of Jean Rafael
saperstein an obnoxious friend of Aziz
ansari's Tom Haverford was created just
for Schwartz I don't like all this
negativity man why don't you turn that
frizz on Upside Dizzy huh the more Ben
Schwartz appeared on Parks and
Recreation the more fans fell in love
with jean-ralphio eventually the
character's family members made
appearances including his sister Mona
Lisa played by Jenny slate and his
father played by Henry Winkler as Jean
ralphio Schwartz often improvised his
lines stealing every scene in the
process Schwartz is no stranger to
improv he came up through Upright
Citizens Brigade theater and even had a
long-form improv show with Silicon
Valley star Thomas middleditch several
blooper reels from Parks and Recreation
showcase Schwartz's ability to make his
co-stars break character
new parks and recreation pairing seemed
as unlikely as Andy Dwyer and April
Ludgate Chris Pratt and Aubry Plaza's
chemistry together was undeniable but
Michael sure didn't consider them as a
couple until the season one finale Rock
Show in a brief moment improvised by
Plaza April is the only one who
understands Andy's taste in music I
don't really like to Define it so
undefinable rock you know again the term
Rock I think defines it I totally know
what you mean the characters got another
chance to bond in the season 2 episode
hunting trip which found the two alone
in the office while the rest of the
staff goes on a hunting trip together
while Andy is still lamenting his
breakup with Anne April gives him a
hickey as a way to make her jealous this
moment becomes the impetus for the pairs
will they won't they story throughout
the rest of seasons 2 and 3. April and
Andy get married in season three after
dating for a month which is perfectly in
character for both of them as the series
went on Andy and April's relationship
became a highlight for many fans the two
were especially hilarious when they role
played as their alter egos Burt Macklin
and Janet snakehold April also helped
Andy check off items on his bucket list
such as holding a thousand dollars in
cash in his hands and becoming an action
star they may not be the most functional
adults but the pairs sure do have a
delightful relationship
oh babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married still
Parks and Recreation came to an end in
2015 after seven seasons but the show
was lived on through the growing
popularity of streaming services like
Netflix and Hulu the fan base has
remained active on social media as well
and the cast often speaks fondly about
the show in hindsight this persistent
popularity led to a Parks and Recreation
special a one-off episode filmed during
the covid-19 pandemic catching up on the
characters in quarantine Leslie and
April also appeared on Saturday Night
Live in January of 2023. this did not go
unnoticed by NBC when they launched
their own streaming service peacock
according to deadline NBC Universal paid
approximately nine figures to move Parks
and Recreation over to Peacock from
Netflix the actual cost is apparently
not even close to what they paid for the
office which is upwards of 500 million
dollars the show Stars may have gone on
to other projects but they and their
fans can always come back to Pawnee
Indiana
foreign